our portfolio of companies does 75 000
per working hour 40 hours per week and
building this has taken a long time and
so what i share with you in this video
is 10 lessons that i have learned in
observing all of those companies over
the last you know 10
years let's start with the first one and
if you don't know i am my name's auction
mosey i own acquisition.com it's
portfolio of companies does all that
stuff all right so the first one is uh
something that actually learned from the
private equity managing partner who
acquired two of the companies uh last
year number one is that most things
don't matter and a few things matter a
lot and you can achieve outsized returns
by only focusing on those few and so
once you figure out those few things you
can ruthlessly eliminate the rest and
the thing is is that this is very hard
because a lot of us get really excited
we go to workshops we go to seminars we
see ads on facebook and we think oh you
know i should be doing this new sexy
thing and the reality is that there are
very few things that can give you 10x
50x results and so if you just focus on
those few things you can get a lot of
other stuff wrong and i think all of us
could use more second chances and more
padding right and so if you can just
focus on those big things you can make
those mistakes and still succeed and so
when the private equity partner who kind
of taught me this lesson is when i was
observing some of the things that he's
doing with jim launch prestige labs
during the last quarterly uh meeting you
know our team was going through all the
things that uh that they were doing to
kind of you know improve the company and
grow and i could tell that he was only
interested in only two conversations
that occurred number one is that you
know we were building in some technology
into the business because that would
yield a much bigger multiple for the
business in the future the second was
accretive which means basically value
additive m a so looking at companies
that are similar in the space that they
could roll in to the overall
conglomerate because in his mind he knew
that the only way to you know sell that
you know those two particular companies
for over you know 250 million or more
which is the the goal would probably
come from those two main things and the
rest of it for the most part he just
considered blocking and tackling which
was just yeah of course you know we'll
grow we'll do these things but the big
nuts the big levers uh for getting that
growth was going to come from very few
things and that is where he allocated
all of his attention and to me that was
a very important lesson to witness that
was number one number two is that the
size of your slice of the pie matters
more than the shape all right so a lot
of people's egos mine included right 100
of the pie which is a perfect circle
right we want 100 of the pie but our
bank accounts only care about how much
that slice of pie weighs right if you
are one percent owner on facebook you'll
be significantly wealthier than owning
100 of probably the small business that
you have right and so the thing is is
that in order to do that it means you
have to give a place to the pie because
it takes more people to build big things
right and so getting other people tied
and compensated for the achievement of
your vision is one of the key things
that is required and i noticed that
because as soon as we've uh done profit
sharing plans and given you know bonus
pools and things like that to tie
leaders into the success and the
achievement of the overall vision we got
significantly outsized returns in excess
of what we had given up and so it's just
the the weight of the slice that we have
or that we keep is now worth more than
if we had had 100 and not had that
incremental growth through enlisting the
spirit and willpower and drive of other
people right and one of the interesting
things that i've witnessed is that if
you look at the richest people in the
world the vast majority of them do not
own 100 of their company i mean the vast
majority don't even own the majority of
their company look at basis only it's 10
of amazon at this point elon owns 20 and
17 percent of spacex and tesla right and
so there's you know if we take lessons
from these people it's that the more
people you make wealthy the more wealthy
you will become right and it's true from
a business to consumer standpoint if you
sell kind of b2b but also just from the
overall infrastructure of the of the
marketplace like the more people you
have who are rooting for you because
they are vested in your success the more
you will ultimately make and this is
difficult for our egos and this took me
way way too long to realize number three
is that big things take time all right
um i knew that when i was you know
younger in the entrepreneurial game i
was very obsessed with fast wins fast
wins fast ones what can we do this week
what can we do this month rather than
thinking 10 years out 20 years out and
the thing is is that when i and i
learned this lesson from andrew chung
who owns panda express and he lives in
the building above me he actually owns
this entire building uh which he bought
for i think like 150 million and he owns
the building next to us which he bought
for 5.6 billion big dude and he owns 2
600 locations of panda express and he
owns them all 100 he has no franchisees
no licensors and when asked on an
interview what the keys to success were
there were two themes that that came out
one he said your customer must
absolutely love your product and number
two is that big things take time right
it took him 45 years and he still
continues to grow this day and the
majority of the growth has happened in
the last you know five years or so this
year he opened up 600 locations of those
two of those 2 600. so a huge chunk
happens near the end and that depth of
expertise takes time to build because
remember we're competing against other
people who've also been doing this for a
long period of time and the one thing
that we can take to our advantage is if
we've just been doing this longer right
and we get these compounding results
that happen over a long period of time
and so i think rather than making this a
patient's platitude thinking of this as
what could i do for a very very long
period of time because the only things
that will be very big will take a long
time and i must be motivated to not
change my course or see some shiny
object that's going to take me away from
my overarching vision or goal and so i
think when i started thinking this way
the companies that i had continued to
grow better with higher quality people
and made higher quality decisions
because it wasn't about the short win it
was just is this gonna matter in 10
years and what are the few things that
will matter in that long period of time
and then let's ruthlessly limit
everything else and just focus on those
things number four brand matters a lot
all right and so this is something that
took me again a very long time to
understand and the way that you build
brand is that you make promises and you
keep promises not only to the level that
you made the promise but in excess of
that so you make a promise and then you
deliver above that promise brand is
simply the reputation that you have in
the marketplace is what people say
behind your back right and what most
people don't have is the invisible hand
behind the scenes that's pushing higher
and higher return on advertising because
more and more people have heard of you
from a friend before seeing your ads or
your reach outs or whatever it is that
you use to get customers right and so
what happens is that most people do the
opposite of that they make big promises
they under fulfill and then over time
their cost of acquisition raises beyond
the increase in cost per impression or
cost of time on their labor because they
have an invisible hand that's
suppressing their growth which is
negative word of mouth which is much
stronger and much more viral than
positive word of mouth and so people
don't understand they think they blame
the platforms they blame you know pixel
changes and things like that when the
reality is that they have negative word
of mouth that's working against them and
they just don't know how big of a deal
it is right and so the beauty of brand
if you build it the right way is that it
gives you this is the tactical behind
brand is that branding gives you premium
pricing power all right if you look at a
cup of coffee that's plain a cup of
coffee at starbucks they can charge you
know four or five times the price if you
look at a white t-shirt that's plain and
you look a white t-shirt that has a nike
logo on it they can charge 10 times more
you put a gucci logo on it you can
charge 100 times more right and so what
the brand does is give you pricing power
and that pricing power translates
directly to bottom line profits right
and so when you have that branding power
you can have outsized profits compared
to the marketplace and give yourself a
competitive moat that over time if
things if cost of goods increase or
supply chain gets broken down the people
who are trading in commodities and do
not have a brand behind them will go out
of business whereas you will have the
padding of your profit margin to
continue to weather the storm and endure
for the long haul number five simple
scales fancy fails all right when i look
at the companies that we have that are
the biggest in the portfolio they have
the simplest business models because
scale creates complexity all on its own
you don't need to add complexity we
don't need to help complexity exist it
already exists at scale and so we have
to make the fundamental units as simple
as humanly possible we have to make our
offer suite as simple as humanly
possible we have to make the customer
journey as simple as humanly possible
and who we serve as simple as humanly
possible so we can streamline our
messaging streamline the customer
experience streamline the products we
streamline the pricing so that the
customers understand what we're doing
the sales team understands what we're
doing the customer service team and
success team understands what we're
doing and so all we're doing is adding
more to that machine rather than adding
uh complexity and adding new doodads and
i love this quote because i think it's a
really good one which is do not risk the
empire for a pot of gold which i heard
from my good friend uh charon cervaza
who sold his company for a zillion
dollars all right um and i just really
really like that so simple scans fancy
fails and a lot of times we need to
ignore the shiny objects that are sent
here to test how good we are as
entrepreneurs and how dedicated we are
to keeping things simple because if you
cannot keep it simple a lot of times it
means you do not understand it which
means you may not even understand your
own business number six emotions are the
enemy when i look at the portfolio
founders who are the most successful
they are the least emotionally reactive
they are the most rational in their
decision making they are the most
long-term minded and so one of the one
of the the truisms that i've adopted is
nothing is ever as good or as bad as we
expect except for the things that we
don't expect all right and so i'll
unpack that so from a tactical
perspective when we make these
projections we think there's this new
thing that we want to add a lot of times
it's not going to be as good as we think
it is right it's usually going to be
less than that and to the same degree
the equal opposite side of the coin is
if there's some threat that comes in
most times it's not as bad as we think
it is or it's going to be so we
catastrophize uh negatively worse than
it really is and we and we project that
something's gonna be much better than it
is and most times it's in the middle
it's less than our imagination could
anticipate except for the things that we
never expected which is why the al size
returns often come from things that we
didn't expect at all right and so most
times we need to be much more
conservative in our estimates on either
direction so that we do not become
emotionally reactive and swayed by the
greed or excitement of the upside or the
depression and fear of the downside and
i can tell you the amount of times that
i thought i was going to lose the
different companies that i've owned over
time is a lot and the amount of times
that we have lost them is zero up to
this point you know in the last 10 years
and so a lot of times we think things
are much worse than they are and we make
bad decisions because we think we're up
against a wall we think that things are
going to die and so that's not true
that's your mind fooling you and i think
one of the disciplines from the
character traits that has to be honed
over time is a decrease in emotional
reactivity number seven level 10 talent
is only attracted to level 10
opportunities i learned this from steven
schwartzman who wrote what it takes he's
the founder of blackstone now he's worth
i think 30 billion and his and
blackstone i think manages almost 700
billion dollars so a lot of money and he
said this very well so i'm not going to
try and pair it as as though it's my own
he says you need level 10 talent to
build anything big right and so we have
to think long and hard about how big
this can be so that others people's
dreams can fit inside of it and so like
if you want to build a dry cleaning a
local dry cleaning business there's
nothing wrong with that it's just that
level 10 talent is not going to probably
be attracted to that opportunity and so
we have to think long and hard now if
you think my true goal you're not just
saying this but it has to be true to you
is that i want to build a different way
for people to clean their clothes in a
convenient way because that's something
that you are driven to do and you think
you can do it for a very long period of
time and you don't think you'll get
distracted by other things that are
shiny objects etc you will be able to
build it to a size where other people
start to believe you and then you will
be able to enlist level 10 talent and i
also learned this one from sharon
because i like this quote a lot he said
your best talent isn't even on your team
yet the best talent exists in the future
and so we have to make room for those
people which goes back to the slice of
pie and things that i was talking about
earlier all right number eight in terms
of lessons that i've learned in building
our portfolio compounding in business
creates breathtaking results when you
add the one ingredient that people hate
the most time everyone hates to add time
because everyone is impatient and if you
look at the people who i think in my
opinion i look up to or the most
successful they have one thing under
control which is their impulses they can
control their impulses because they see
that adding time is the single greatest
variable to achieving the outsized
returns that you were looking for and so
one of the things that i've noticed of
the portfolio companies that we have the
biggest companies our portfolio obsess
over the 101 improvements versus trying
to double in 90 days they can
extrapolate the fact that a 10 per
quarter growth rate means a 40x growth
rate over a decade and they can actually
think in decades because you know what
right now if you're doing a million
bucks a year if 10 years make you do 40
million a year would you be okay with
that you don't need to swing for the
fences every time if you just hit
singles and you do that consistently set
goals that are far more achievable will
be that people will actually believe
they can do and c gives you room to
overachieve those things and i think
that the goals that i have set for the
portfolio companies and my own companies
has consistently got more and more
conservative now some people set goals
that are completely silly right and you
know they're they're useless in that
they're so achievable that they're not
worth anything and so that's not who i'm
talking to and i would say the vast
majority of entrepreneurs i talk with
that is not their problem they're
usually setting goals that are way too
unrealistic and that goes back to the
expectations of thinking that things are
going to be better than they really are
right and so we have to set goals that
in my opinion if we were just to do
these things and that were the
assumption if we just did 10 or quarter
how much bigger would it be at the end
of the year if we did just 10 a quarter
for the next two years how much bigger
would we be right and obviously give
ourselves rooms to overachieve those
things but if we just did those things
what would it look like and a lot of
times it would look really really juicy
but most people are unwilling to take
that short term goal and say i'm just
going to hit the 10 we're just gonna
we're going to make sure that beyond any
shadow of doubt we can hit that right
because that is where the breathtaking
results occur is that those one percent
five percent 10 improvements that happen
over the very long period of time and
that is what creates the magic and
compounding right a lot of people talk
about compounding from an investment
perspective but if you are in your own
business shifting your hat a little bit
more to the investor hat even though all
of your net worth or probably the
majority of your net worth is in your
company if you can think about it like
an investor you will start to getting
the investor-like returns which is
probably what you want rather than the
erratic unreliable you know it would do
or die type of mentality that happens
especially in the earlier stages of a
business but as you mature
in the business itself and the business
matures the thinking must change number
nine any number no matter how big
multiplied by zero is still zero all
right and so risks are to be respected
right the biggest companies take actions
that have very little downside all right
and so most times um or i'll say this
you would only take a company-sized risk
where you put your company on the line
when not doing so risks the company more
all right and so that's the big thing is
i see people people who want to be
portfolio companies so companies doing
you know three million five million et
cetera who right when we hop on the
phone with them like hey i want to do
this big thing and i'm like you know
that's extremely risky for for the
business at the size right now they're
like yeah but we have to do it and i
always kind of think do we though like
do we really because the answer is
probably no and it's usually emotions
that are causing a distortion in reality
for the founder and so you only take a
company size risk when you really know
that if you do not do if inaction right
or continuing to do what you were doing
um will create a failure now we've heard
the case studies of kodak you know you
know losing their business and you know
blockbuster losing their business but
there are far far far far more times
where business was perfectly fine and
the founder basically destroyed it
because of their own irrational fears or
excitement or exuberance over a new
opportunity that was not core to the
business and then put the business on
the line and lost and so you do not take
company size risks unless the company is
truly on the line and you have very
strong evidence to support that which is
in the vast majority minority of
circumstances and most times if you were
solving a problem that most people
suffer from because you already have
product market fit because people
already buying the thing people are
always going to want to make more money
people are always going to want to
improve skills people are always going
to want uh to lose weight people are
always going to want to have better
relationships people are always going to
want there are a lot of things that
those demands those desires will not
disappear and the reason that we invest
in businesses that are non-tech related
for the most part is because we know
that we can consistently i would say 80
portfolio is not tech based right so the
vast majority of businesses we know that
if we can do the boring work we can
repeat successful actions once we find
product market fit where people want
this thing solved and we can solve it
well most of the growth comes from not
putting the company on the line but
doing the things that no one wants to do
which is simply improving simply getting
better at fulfilling the promise and
i'll give you a quick story on this
dragon dictation way long ago there was
a dictating software this is probably
like 20 years ago that came out very
early days in computing because a lot of
people weren't even good at typing this
so they created dragon dictation they
created a 2.0 version of direct
dictation that had zero new features
zero all it did was be more accurate at
dictation when people would speak they
would get more uh accurate results on
the screen and they were praised by so
many people for making this move but the
thing is is that most of us don't want
to do that hard work of making the thing
that we actually sell better improving
the experience decreasing the the time
to experience result decreasing the time
to value improving the customer health
score
segmenting customers by their needs and
and trying to match those better with
the products we have a lot of people
don't want to do that work because it
feels boring feels heavy it's not sexy
it's not exciting but that is where you
drive the outsize value that is where
you build the brand that gives you the
premium pricing power that is where you
build the word of mouth that ultimately
creates the competitive moat that you
can stand on as a company for years not
days number 10 sell what the customer
wants not what you want to build all
right and this was a big one all right
because our egos want to matter but the
thing is is that we don't matter we want
to be right but what matters more is
what the data says and so we have to
lead with data rather than ego and i
mean there was a company um that we have
in our portfolio that really wanted to
do this uh at a new ascension a new
product line that was going to be uh an
upsell and a very high ticket thing um
in their business and i felt strongly
that it was not what the the clients
wanted they're like dude but we're so
good at this this we could provide so
much value et cetera and i said well
let's just let's just survey right and
let's survey this is what i think we
should we should offer which was more of
what people were already buying just an
increased version of the thing or this
new thing right that's really exciting
for you guys and so we did the survey
and guess what came back 85 percent of
the people who were customers just
wanted more of the thing that they
already had 15 percent wanted the new
shiny thing and so the thing is is that
these types of huge pivotal decisions in
a business can completely off-road you
and destroy your business by simply not
taking the step to listen to your
customer because a lot of times our egos
don't want to listen to that we want to
be right we want to do the thing that
sounds exciting to us but that a lot of
times isn't what the business requires
and so what the business requires is a
founder or ceo who's customer centric
who's customer focused who's not focused
on building what they think is exciting
but building exactly what the customer
wants even if it's boring to them and
hell if it's born to you awesome means
you're already probably pretty good at
it right and that is where the depth of
expertise gets built and compounded over
time number 11. this is my the simplest
way of putting business success into a
series of statements all right so the
recipes for success in my opinion can be
boiled down to this make promises keep
promises build brand use brand to
increase pricing power above the market
use extra profits that were supported by
the brand to spur growth through hiring
better people and adding new acquisition
channels give slices of the pie to get a
bigger slice overall and enlist more
people in your vision and then give time
time and that is it so if you don't know
how my name is alex mosey like i said
i'm managing partner at acquisition.com
uh we take three million dollar
companies to 30 million dollars plus and
beyond that is what we do every day you
can find out more at acquisition.com and
uh if you dug this leave some questions
in the in the comments i've been trying
to answer the comments um
more than i have in the past i've been
trying to allocate some time am i
scheduled to do that love you guys mosey
nation you guys are amazing i don't
deserve you i appreciate you nonetheless
and if you're new to the channel welcome
and i'll see you guys on the other side